dirigeants de l'audiovisuel français
comme l'a titré le journal le monde le
18 mai dernier en quelque sorte le
patriarche de l'audiovisuel français et
7 scénario était né peut être parti pour
durer puisque vous pourriez devenir le
président du futur groupe issu de la
fosse une fusion tf1 m6 si celle ci
venait à être réalisée ce projet de
fusion est évidemment au centre des
préoccupations de la commission denquête
nous avons entendu l'ancienne présidente
de l'autorité de la concurrence
ainsi que le président par intérim au
mois de décembre et le sujet revient
très régulièrement devant nous de parts
à la fois les effets qu'il peut susciter
sur pour l'indépendance des réacs des
rédactions mais également en terme de
déséquilibres
potentiel de toute la chaîne de valeur
de la production est aussi les effets
sur le secteur publicitaire au delà de
cet épisode qui trouvera sa conclusion
en fin d'année prochaine avec l'autorité
la décision de l'autorité de la
concurrence vous êtes également un
observateur aiguisé de l'évolution des
médias depuis presque quarante ans nous
avons donc assisté à toutes les
évolutions qui se sont déroulés et qui
ont bien sûr un impact sur le paysage
actuel je pense à l'arrivée des chaînes
privées au développement de la tnt
depuis d'internet à l'éruption des
plateformes de streaming et donc
dernièrement à un mouvement de
concentration entre quelques grands
groupes d'origine industrielle qui
suscite des interrogations légitimes la
commission sera donc heureuse de
bénéficier de votre expérience comme de
votre expertise en la matière
je vous propose de fonctionner comme le
font à chaque audition cdg vous donner
la parole pour dix minutes 10 minutes
pas plus afin que nous puissions vous
poser des questions et ce sera le
rapporteur qui commencera la première
série de questions cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du sénat et elle fera l'objet d'un
compte rendu qui sera publié enfin je
rappelle pour la forme qu un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
denquête seraient passibles des peines
prévues aux articles 4 134 tirs et 13 14
et 15 du code pénal je vous précise
également qu'il vous appartient le cas
échéant d'indiquer vos éventuels liens
d'intérêts ou conflits d'intérêts en
relation avec l'objet de la commission
denquête je vais vous inviter monsieur
de tavernost a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite c'est en disant je
le jure je vous remercie et donc je vous
donne la parole pour dix minutes
il se met en marche automatiquement en
fait non là il sait pas ouais
mais bon c'est le président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs
je vous entends ici de la vision d'un
entrepreneur et non pas d'un
propriétaire un entrepreneur satisfait
mais préoccupé
satisfait d'avoir créé avec jean drucker
d'abord avec ensuite les équipes autour
de thomas valentin un groupe qui
aujourd'hui se porte bien le bilan de
l'activité de l'année 2021 le démontrera
préoccuper aussi parce que les mutations
sont extrêmement profonde que la
législation et la réglementation n'est
pas toujours adaptée à ces évolutions et
que les mouvements sont nécessaires pour
faire face à ces nouveaux enjeux
internes effectivement à d'abord
d'expliquer pourquoi le groupe se porte
bien après un rapide historique
de bientôt 35 ans puisque nous aurons 35
ans le 1er mars 2022 prochain la
première raison du succès de m6 est me
semble-t-il la stabilité de son
actionnariat
est sans doute celle de ses équipes
comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs pour nos
collègues de tf1 j'ai connu pendant
cette période dix présidents tous
présidents différents de l'audiovisuel
de la télévision publique
enfant de la loi de 86 nous avons joué
des coudes pour nous imposer constatant
avec mon collègue de tf1 de l'époque que
le la télévision le marché publicité de
la télévision stagner nous avons décidé
grâce au digital de lancer la télévision
par satellite tps qui fut un succès
puisque dans les années 90 nous avons eu
jusqu'à 1 million 800 mille abonnés
la concurrence exacerbée la nécessité de
regrouper les difficultés du groupe
canal+ ont amené une fusion première
concentration du secteur auquel a
participé canal+
en constituant à l'époque un groupe très
important de la télévision payante ce
qu'il a probablement sauvé à partir de
cette époque la concentration est
parfois une nécessité
ensuite est arrivé la tnt ce devait être
selon moi la première occasion de
conforter des acteurs historiques
français et européens en réalité les a
affaiblis la priorité était donnée aux
premiers entrants que je qualifie
souvent de premier sorti il n'y a pas eu
d'investissements dans la création ou
très peu mais des reventes qui vous sont
contraints modifié d'ailleurs sous je
crois l'initiative de de votre
rapporteur
a modifié la législation ultérieurement
pour taxer les reventes nous avons
cherché à nous adapter avec une plus
grande diversification nous nous sommes
heurtés alors à des difficultés liées à
l'intégration verticale alors que celle
ci se développe dans tous les autres
pays dont le cinéma nous avons fait ce
que nous avons pu faire grâce à une
station et je suis très fier de nos
succès puisque en 2021 nous avons été le
premier distributeur français en matière
de cinéma nous avons le premier film en
termes d'entrées nous avons été le
premier éditeur vidéo grâce à notre
filiale health ndm six films
nous avons également c'est ce qui est
peut-être le garder un succès investi
dans le non linéaire dès 2008 avec
aujourd'hui ce qui s'appelle 6 play
c'est à dire de la fri mode de la
télévision accès gratuit non linéaire et
qui est aujourd'hui un pilier du
développement du groupe
enfin avec nos deux collègues de france
et vision et de tf1 nous avons créé
salto j'y reviendrai dans un instant
lancé en 2020 le développement de m6 est
ainsi fait par croissance interne à deux
exceptions près nous avons senti le
besoin de nous développer encore une
fois dans un marché de la publicité
stagnante en rachetant la radio à notre
actionnaire rtl en 2017 en acquérant les
chaînes de lagardère en 2019
notamment avec la chaîne gulli
mais ce que nous avons fait aujourd'hui
et malgré notre bonne santé est
insuffisant sur la production du du fait
de règles très strictes d'indépendance
nous n'avons pas pu acquérir
et certaines sociétés de production qui
sont venus nous voir pour se développer
pourquoi parce que le premier effet
qu'on a en en prenant ces sociétés
production c'est que nous aurions pu
plus travailler avec elle du fait des
décrets son indépendance
sûr je fais une incidente pour répondre
peut-être par anticipation une question
de monsieur assouline sur deux sur gulli
qui est une des chaînes que nous
pourrions envisager de céder je dis bien
une des scènes nous nous heurtons une
vraie difficulté en ce qui concerne les
producteurs les producteurs qui pourrait
être candidat a racheté cette chaîne ne
pourrait plus produire pour cette chaîne
du fait des décrets d'indépendance et de
la convention du lit je voudrais vous
faire toucher du doigt la rigidité du
système dans lequel nous sommes
quand vous possédez une chaîne gulli on
doit avoir trois chaînes sur ces trois
chaînes ne scelle la poutre pour être
possible
les candidats sont notamment dans la
production pour développer un secteur
d'animation or ce secteur d'animation la
convention de lully oblige
empêche d'avoir toutes parts de
coproduction et oblige à travailler avec
de la production indépendante pour cent
pour cent de l'animation de l'embellie
il est évident que les producteurs
intéressés ne vont pas prendre le risque
de non modification de la convention
donc on est devant la une difficulté qui
est intrinsèquement en défaveur du
système je reviendrai peut-être pour
votre question sur si vous en avez une
sur les chaînes éventuellement a cédé
pour dans le cas du nouveau groupe
sur le streaming pourquoi c'est
insuffisant salto avec de très bonnes
équipes avec une association qui a
marché très bien avec notre collègue de
france télévisions et mon collègue
gilles pélisson de tf1 nous avons monté
une structure mais dès lors qu'on est
concurrent c'est très difficile puisque
ça fait partie de notre corps de métier
le streaming donc c'est très difficile
de faire une société commune et la
deuxième chose comme on est concurrent
la dlc amis des règles extrêmement
strictes de fonctionnement nous ne
pouvons plus être au conseil
d'administration nous ne pouvons plus
avoir le détail des budgets nous ne
pouvons plus nous engager sur des
productions précise dans un ailleurs les
prix et donc son fonctionnement rend
l'activité extrêmement difficile et
toutes ces contraintes que je vous dis
aucune des plates formes confiante de
les ans vous n'avez pas dit ce n'est
plus amazon warner qui lé moindre
concurrence j'y reviendrai si vous
voulez bien tout à l'heure enfin
insuffisant aussi puisque le marché
publicitaire de la télévision
n'augmentent pas il a eu des plus et des
moins avec la fin de la publicité après
20 heures sur la télévision publique et
qui déstabilisera nouveau totalement le
secteur si je n'en revenais dessus mais
je ne pense pas que ce soit dans les
intentions le et avec des plus et des
moins puisque par exemple pour une
chaîne comme levier on a limité la
publicité alimentaire pour les enfants
on a enlevé un certain nombre on a par
contre permis la publicité sur la
distribution y ait eu des plus et des
moins mais globalement le secteur est
resté au même niveau qu'il ya dix ans en
matière d'investissements publicitaires
à la télévision et pendant ce temps là
je citerai la phase monsieur ses tricks
le directeur général de l'union des
marques le digital est devenu le premier
média français c'est un constat et cette
phrase date de 2016
aujourd'hui donc nous devons aller plus
loin malgré les efforts que nous avons
faits pour nous adapter dans la
production dans le streaming dans la
publicité
et dans la diversification
pourquoi nous devons aller plus loin
parce que aujourd'hui la concurrence et
je reviendrai pas sur les propos que mon
actionnaire thomas sera de vous êtes
tenus ici même je donnerai simplement
deux exemples
68 % de l'audience de la télévision
linéaire aujourd'hui est fait par les
plus de 50 ans 68% il était que ça
n'était que 50 % en 2010 donc
l'évolution est spectaculaire
la part de 2 des moins de 50 ans dans la
télévision diminue entre 5 et 10% chaque
année il y a eu une interruption liée au
vide puisque les français étaient
coincés chez eux mais cette interruption
est de courte durée nous nous comparons
maintenant à 2019
donc il n'est pas il n'est pas
impossible de prendre le risque de subir
ce à quoi la presse écrite a dû se
confronter il nous faut donc changer
complètement fortement et rapidement
alors dans nous avons regardé toutes les
solutions possibles pour nous adapter à
cette nouvelle cette nouvelle donne
sachant que nous avons des contraintes
des contraintes qui sont des contraintes
d'investissement
nous devons accélérer nos
investissements le streaming très
fortement nous devons adapter notre
programmation au nouvel environnement de
concurrence et notamment développer
l'information développer les magazines
développer la partie événementielle de
nos programmes linéaire
et nous devons continuer à faire du
sport le sport est une denrée qui était
cher tous ces investissements j'ai
évidemment accélérées dans le domaine de
la fiction est ce que je dis c'est que
la création c'est aussi une affaire de
cash flow et donc c'est la bonne santé
de deux de nos sociétés qui permettra de
maintenir un écosystème français
relativement relativement puissant alors
pourquoi
le ce projet de fusion est une bonne
réponse en quoi est il une bonne réponse
alors premièrement
si nous nous engageons dans cette voie
si les deux actionnaires le groupe
bouygues le groupe bertelsmann rtl group
ont accepté de s'engager dans cette voie
qui n'était pas la plus commode c'était
pas là c'est pas la plus facile compte
tenu des difficultés de toute nature
administrative juridique
ce n'est pas toujours facile de mélanger
les cultures de deux entreprises qui ont
été concurrentiel pendant 35 ans
pourquoi on s'est engagé dans celle là
c'est qu'elle nous semble être la bonne
réponse dont le fait ou premièrement
elle accélérera la transformation de nos
sociétés en amenant une des
investissements plus massifs dans la
production et notamment dans lés
streaming qui est le coeur même de notre
projet
deuxièmement elle préserve l'identité
des marques que nous avons c'est à dire
des chaînes que nous conserverons il
n'est pas question de brouiller cette
identité sinon vous perdrez tout dans
cette dans cette fusion
c'est le cas notamment dans les
rédactions comme comme la très très
précisément dit
monsieur rabais thomas sera meyer et je
pourrais vous explique l'hostilité en
quoi nous avons appliqué ce principe
dans la dans le rapprochement m6 et rtl
nous avons fait des synergies et nous
avons préserver l'indépendance des deux
des deux sociétés en matière de
rédaction
l'information de m6 notamment à
destination des moins de 50 ans marche
très bien le soir nous fêtons nous
faisons entre 3 et 4 millions de
spectateurs tous les soirs marche très
bien
l'information de rtl qui n'est pas celle
de m6 marche extrêmement bien mais nous
annonçons par exemple tous les soirs
l'invité qui lie à sur rtl nous invitons
le présent large et je crois que jeudi
chez madame nature à
nous aurons une annonce dans le 19h45 de
m6 ça s'appelle des synergies ça
préserve l'indépendance de chacun et
c'est ce que nous avons menée sur rtl et
qui fonctionne correctement
vous demander de conclure pardon je vous
demander de conclure pour que nous avons
dépassé l'éliminer donc à vos questions
sur sur la sur l'intérêt de la fusion
c'est bien sûr aller plus loin dans ce
domaine nous allons y revenir
la parole est aux rapporteurs
bonjour monsieur de tavernot
votre ancienneté à la tête de ce votre
groupe fait que
on a assisté ensemble pas la même place
de nombreuses auditions touchant des
sujets divers pas toujours d'ailleurs
conflictuelle où nous étions à vouloir
comprendre aider parce que nous savons à
quel point m6 a eu et a une place
particulière dans le paysage audiovisuel
notamment et vous vous en vente y ait
beaucoup
vous étiez vous le disiez le seul groupe
indépendant c'est à dire vous faisiez du
média et que du média et c'était souvent
un argument pour un petit peu titiller
vos concurrents dans le paysage
audiovisuel et moi j'aimais bien ça et
justement là maintenant le sujet
principal avec vous c'est que c'est vous
qui allez être absorbé par un groupe qui
n'a pas la même caractéristique puisque
lui
sa
vocation principale est dans le btp la
téléphonie et donc vous allez ça nous a
été confirmée hier vous allez bien être
le président de la future entité donc
avec rôle tout à fait fondamental à la
tête d'un groupe qui dépendra d'autres
choses que de la coeur de métier médias
ceci dit ce qui nous intéresse est de
comprendre toutes les tenants et les
aboutissants de ce cette fusion même si
c'est l'autorité de la concurrence sur
le plan économique qui donnera son avis
et l'art comme qui le donnera sur la
question du pluralisme et de la
démocratie
nous on aborde tout ça en même temps
parce que tous nous intéresse
vous pouvez vous chiffrer s'agissant du
groupe m6
la diminution des ressources
publicitaires ces dernières années ainsi
que l'augmentation des coûts
d'acquisition
qui serait à l'origine de votre projet
de fusion puisque c'est bien parce que
vous dites qu'il ya du minutieux
des ressources publicitaires et
l'augmentation des coûts d'acquisition
qu' il était impératif pour votre groupe
de d'aller vers cette fusion est ce que
vous pouvez nous le chiffre est une
réponse brève un papa long parce que
comme ça je peux composer plusieurs qui
nous permettent d'avoir des éléments de
formation précis
alors
cela pour tard d'abord sur sur
l'actionnariat puisque vous me posez une
question d un ce que ça vous sur
l'actionnariat vous n'êtes plus
simplement une société média puisque
vous appartiendrez y ait un groupe qui
ne fait pas que du meilleur c'est ce
qu'a compris le sens de votre question
d'où le le coeur de métier n'est pas les
médias voilà alors moi je viens d'une
société dont le coeur de métier n'était
pas du tout les médias qui s'appelle la
lyonnaise des eaux c'est un métier était
un peu parallèle à cela et qui est à
l'origine de la création m6 puisque je
suis rentré la lyonnaise des eaux en
décembre 1985 et que j'ai proposé au
président de l'époque de concourir pour
une fréquence qui se sur le réseau 6 et
nous avons pris un associé qui était à
l'époque le groupe rtl pour nous
associer qu'était un praticien puisque
nous ne connaissions pas bien
l'audiovisuel et donc nous sommes
associés et c'est un mariage qui a duré
très longtemps puisqu'il a duré jusque
années 2000 et il n'y a eu aucun sujet
de difficultés pour développer un groupe
médian avec une société qui ne faisait
pas dont le corps du business les pompes
funèbres les avait des tas de choses qui
était quand même assez différentes de
l'activité média ils ont été des
partenaires extrêmement
loyau ils ont financé des déficits très
importants pendant les quatre premières
années ils ont lu un écosystème il se
développer dans le câble également moins
de succès et donc l'actionnariat à
respecter l'indépendance du management
de la même façon que ce que vous a dit
thomas sera 2 lorsque nous avons
continué seul avec rtl group non pas que
rtl group et voulu prendre la possession
du groupe simplement suez à l'époque
c'était lyonnaise des eaux devenue suez
avait d'autres ambitions que et ils se
sont reconcentrés dans le secteur de
l'énergie donc je n'ai eu aucune
difficulté à travailler avec un groupe
qui ne faisait autre chose que du média
ils nous ont accompagné une partie de la
réalité de remédier à une très petite
partie de l'activité et donc je pense
que la famille bouygues et le groupe
bouygues qui sont depuis 35 ans dans la
télévision qui ont les règles qui sont
disons analogues et c'est ce que je
crois que vous avez été soumis hier à
celle de fonctionnement vers telle route
je n'aurai pas de difficulté et et je
suis très heureux de la confiance qu'ils
m'accordent pour éventuellement porter
le projet si celui ci aboutit en ce qui
concerne les chiffres que vous me
demander sur quelle est la diminution
éventuelle de nos recettes publicitaires
et qu'elle est là
l'augmentation des coûts des programmes
alors sur la diminution des recettes
publicitaires globalement nous sommes
relativement stable en matière de
recettes publicitaires simplement cette
stabilité marque des orientations soudée
aujourd'hui
nous nous nous
nous souhaitons nous voulons et nous
nous agissons pour que le streaming les
recettes qui viennent du streaming
compense la perte des recettes du
linéaire et la deuxième chose je pense
qu'on est un peu au bout d'un système
pourquoi on est un peu ou d'un système
car quand vous avez la durée les coûteux
programmes constants serait bien bien
expliquer ça parce que ça pour moi c'est
vraiment important
la télévision linéaire à programme
constants vous mettez le même programme
ya dix ans vous le mettez aujourd'hui où
le mettez dans dix ans
aujourd'hui nous perdons entre 5 et 10%
sur ce qu'on appelle nous la cible
commerciale
nous avons pu jusqu'à présent
compensé par une certaine augmentation
des tarifs d'une part et surtout un
remplissage dont le public se plaint par
ailleurs les fameuses 12 minutes par
heure et les multis coupure publicitaire
nous avons pu compenser 7,7 cette baisse
de la durée d'ecoute skins ce qui nous
amène à une stabilité des recettes que
je viens vous devez indiquer mais il ya
deux phénomènes qui se passe
premièrement les plateformes et le
développement on est habitué le public à
avoir des programmes sans publicité et
donc nous devons être très vigilants
c'est tout de nos très fortes
contraintes d'avenir pour avoir des
services qui ont moins de publicité
défunt a lancé il ya quelques quelques
mois un service de streaming sans
publicité en othe et et nous nous
l'avons lancée sur orange nous savons
que le public est sensible à un public
et c'est la raison pour laquelle moi qui
suis un défenseur du service public mais
t'es pas de publicité après 20h sur ses
listes unitaires ce mec ne le faut pas
le grand défenseur
le nom cela dit plus sérieusement c'est
très important pour nous que de ne pas
avoir un excès publicitaire aujourd'hui
on a compensé la baisse
de l'audience que nous commercialisons
par une augmentation du volume et des
prix nous savons que ça ne durera pas
nous savons que ça durera pas donc il
faut que cette baisse de la durée
d'ecoute linéaire nous la compensation
par dunod millière c'est ce que nous
faisons avec la fraude c'est ce que nous
faisons un peu avec salto c'est ce que
nous devons faire à bride abattue à
bride abattue et nous ne pouvons pas le
faire seul nous ne pouvons pas le faire
seul donc
en gros un mois jeu j'essaie de vous une
contradiction ou dans deux domaines
c'est vos acquis chaque fois dans les
auditions nous disait je suis à tête du
seul grand groupe indépendant de médias
et donc j'ai juste voulu vous dire que
vous pourrez vous n'allez plus pouvoir
le dire
dans vos nouvelles fonctions et puis
ensuite
je vous ai entendu plaider pas que vous
sur sept
ce difficultés avec l'augmentation des
coûts d'acquisition et la diminution des
ressources publicitaires et vous me
dites finalement là que c'est plus une
prévision parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
stable et que donc on va continuer dans
le même ordre d'idées
un des arguments importants que j'ai
bien entendu hier d'ailleurs par
d'autres auditions
c'est que
il ya besoin
d'investissements gigantesque pour
pouvoir avec des technologies qui coûte
cher
avec des recherches de marché dans le
monde nécessaire faire face aux grandes
plate-formes or j'ai regardé le
communiqué que qui a été publié après la
décision de fusion et j'ai pu lire
ceci vous allez m'expliquer ce que ça
veut dire je ne suis pas un grand
économiste mais quand même le groupe
fusionné viserait à distribuer 90 % de
son free cash flow en dividende donc on
ne dit que cette fusion est importante
parce que il faut dégager des moyens
importants pour investir dans la
production la création qui coûte cher
faire face aux plateformes et
vous dites que le groupe fusionné va au
contraire distribué 90% de son free cash
flow au dividende
aux actionnaires doux et pas dans
l'investissement la production
alors plusieurs barques si vous voulez
bien je reviens sur le thème d'
indépendants parce qu'il faut pas qu'il
y ait de confusion sur le terme
indépendant je sais tu t'es bien
dépendance dans mes propos peu de
mémoire j'ai un peu de mémoire là dessus
mes propos c'était par rapport aux
télécoms à l'époque des par rapport aux
séries comme parce que chacun y compris
orange était à l'époque également canal+
était filiale d'un groupe telco et ça ça
nous posait nous un peu des problèmes
parce que dans les mécanismes de
distribution
nous voulions pas être le seul par
rapport à ça donc j'ai beaucoup souligné
l'indépendance pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
législation favorable à l'intégration
telle qu à l'époque tels qu des
solutions dont je fais ce point précis
pour qu'on soit et vous pensez toujours
la même chose avec bouygues telecom
mais je aujourd'hui
les donnes ont changé et heureusement
c'est le rapporteur nous nous adaptons
aux évolutions de marché car si on
s'adapte et pas qu'on restait toujours
sur les mêmes règles nous nous nous
serions morts nous serions plus là alors
sur sur les coûts des programmes je leur
dis pas ce que je vais vous donner un
exemple qui n'est pas tiré de la
production mais je pense que c'est par
des exemples qu'on peut progresser dans
la compréhension du système il y à un
appel d'offres aujourd'hui sur l'équipe
de france de football c'est un événement
protéger donc il est obligatoirement en
clair il peut être aussi sur une
plateforme payante
aujourd'hui le prix que nous payons sur
l'équipe de france nous n'avons plus les
moyens de le payer à l'avenir pourquoi
parce que l'audience est assez
différente et que la commercialisation
linéaire nous pose un certain nombre de
sujets par rapport à la rentabilité
éventuelle de l'équipe de france donc
nous avons fait une offre mais cette
offre est très inférieure à celle qu'il
y avait précédemment nous sommes en
cours d'appel d'offres sur cette
opération ceci vous l'illustrent bien
c'est pas tellement qu'on augmente nos
coûts de programmes c'est que
appartement vous avez des recettes en
diminution liée au phénomène de
diminution d'une ligne r2 des biens nous
devons adapter nos coûts de
programmation sinon nous disparaîtrons
donc ça c'est le deuxième en ce qui
concerne les objectifs de la fusion et
notamment les objectifs financiers il
est très clair que le free cash flow
s'est après investissement donc nous
allons faire des investissements
et puis s'il reste de l'argent les
actionnaires comme ils en ont tout à
fait le droit vous savez aujourd'hui
nous avons dit nous avons un taux de
distribution relativement important
depuis le début ce qui nous a pas du
tout empêché d'investir et à chaque fois
que nous avons eu un investissement à
faire qu'il soit dans tps il était un
risque d'ondée psa gros risque que ce
soit dans salto que ce soit dans dans
les achats de gulli ou rtl nos
actionnaires ont toujours été présents
pour les finances et donc il n'y a aucun
problème de financement de
l'augmentation des investissements que
nous allons faire dans ce nouveau groupe
ça je vous rassure sur ce point la peine
eu un aperçu une grandeur dîner de ce
que ça veut dire dont 4 90% du de ce
qu'il va distribuer un dividende en dans
les budgétisation vous dit le nom c'est
ce qui reste après investissements bon
alors dites-moi tabouret fonds convient
il reste après investissement c'est pas
ça que je calcule en premier oui est ce
que ces calculs en premier c'est de
regarder qu'elle était l'orientation que
nous pouvons de données et aujourd'hui
nous ne connaissons ni le périmètre ni
les conditions adsl ni les conditions
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas vous dire de
quelle dans quelle façon nous avons
chiffré un certain nombre de synergies
ça c'est clair que nous avons fait des
simulations sa tombe de synergies que le
groupe pourrait et une partie des
synergies sera réinvesti dans des
notamment la plateforme de streaming
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
peut être regardée par rapport à la
situation actuelle de m6 est ce que vous
reversez 90% de nos mauvais résultats en
évidence aujourd'hui on leur verse est à
peu près ça de pondeuses années 80 % à
peu près bella ou de 80% le celui du
groupe tf1 à ma connaissance est
inférieur à 60 terre-rouge compte
quelque chose comme ça ouvre à
l'ex-ministre de cannes assiste le bien
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre ça
parce que à chaque fois que nous avons
eu besoin d'argent nous avons eu aucun
problème pour avoir accès à nos
actionnaires à chaque fois donc
lorsque nous aurons besoin de faire des
investissements ils seront importants je
le répète dans le streaming
nos actionnaires j'en suis absolument
persuadé seront prêts à financer les
opérations non je j'entends vos
arguments vos réponses et c'est le débat
continue mais voilà il ya il ya des
arguments qui sont souvent avancés
et d'ailleurs ça avait été le cas dans
une audition de
responsables de boeing
sur le fait que ça va mal
si on fusionne pas où on va serait
creusé par les mains stonor m6
aujourd'hui distribuent des dividendes
tf1 bruit aussi et c'est pas le signe de
ceux qui vont mal et vous envisagez même
dans la fusion de le donner 90% de
dividendes aux actionnaires et voilà
donc se sait c'est juste je surligne des
choses plus que je fais des grandes
analyses alors la dernière question pour
moi dans cette série elle est en
rebondissements mais je vous l'aurais
poser avec une audition de monsieur
thomas rabe hier où il a dit de façon
très affirmative
que lui et le groupe au général
avait une culture vis-à-vis de
l'information une forte culture qui est
d'ailleurs reconnue on peut dire que que
c'est un groupe de médias qui a une
réputation et je le dis souvent
on est un groupe de médias et on apporte
quelque chose à l'information
indépendante qui doit être professionnel
quand on juge au nombre de journalistes
et quand il dit que 1500 journalistes en
allemagne c'est clair que
ça mérite respect mais dans cette
culture il n'y aucune ingérence sur la
rédaction donc j'ai entendu que les
rédactions vous allez me le confirmer ou
pas
tf1 m6 et rtl vont être maintenus et
vont garder leur identité propre même si
je constate que c'est déjà écornée avec
le fait que son visage et des matinales
communes ou des émissions comme lille
parce que ça forcément ça
à la même heure donc c'est plus
distincts que c'est plus deux programmes
sont n'est plus qu'un mais
vous
avec votre franchise connue alors je le
dis pour ceux qui n'ont pas compris
d'aironi tout à l'heure où vous êtes un
des plus grands pourfendeurs du service
public c'est dans une concurrence tout à
fait mais mais vous
vous assumer le fait d'avoir un droit
d'ingérence sur tout ce qui est fait
dans les médias où vous dirigez
et vous l'avez fait à plusieurs reprises
je vous donne un exemple
invité en mai 2015 de l'été n'a biraben
qui vous parle d'une censure de certains
sujets deux journalistes de la chaîne
vous dites que ce ne sont pas des
pressions économiques
ce sont des pressions économiques et nos
politiques je ne peux pas supporter
qu'on dise du mal de nos clients nous
vivons de nos clients vous expliquer un
exemple concret à un moment donné c'est
vous qui parlez il y avait une émission
de capital sur la téléphonie et nous
sommes partie prenante puisque nous
détenons m6 mobile de l'opérateur orange
je leur ai expliqué que si on faisait
une émission sur la téléphonie et
qu'elles étaient bonnes pour ange on
aurait forcément dit que c'était
compréhensible et si elle était mauvaise
pour orange on se serait fâché avec
notre client donc il ya des choses à
éviter
une autre référence à une affaire de
septembre 2012 où il ya un reportage du
magazine capital sur l'opérateur mobile
free avait été repoussée puis
déprogrammés sur la chaîne déclenchant
une pétition des journalistes de la
chaîne privée qui pour était un acte de
censure c'est un article
du figaro
qui rappelle ceux là voilà comment
répondez-vous à cela parce que lui
monsieur thomas sera peu a dit une
ingérence de monsieur de tavernot sur la
ligne éditoriale ne serait pas
compatible avec notre nos esprits notre
état d'esprit
alors je vais vous répondre extrêmement
et grande franchise que vous avez bien
voulu me de cette qualité premièrement
je crois qu'il faut distinguer deux
choses qui sont différentes et il ya une
confusion qui est faite volontairement
ou non entre d'une part ce qu'on appelle
l' ingérence les actionnaires et d'autre
part des dirigeants je pense que il faut
faire le distinguo
soit on vous dit et les actionnaires
d'un côté et les jours de l'autre soit
vous faites une confusion je ne suis pas
actionnaire je suis un dirigeant
révocables à newton
par l'actionnaire révocables à newton
j'ai la responsabilité de l'entreprise
avec mes collègues je suis responsable
pénalement en matière de droit du
travail je suis responsable pénalement
endroits de la diffamation j'y vais
d'ailleurs prochainement la 17e chambre
je suis responsable de l'ensemble de
l'activité et de la défense également
des collaborateurs et les journalistes
entrent en cinq ans vous n'avez vous ne
pouvez pas citer une intervention que
j'ai faite de manière politique y'a pas
une intervention jeudi sous serment que
j'ai fait de manière politique en 35 ans
ça c'est la première des observations la
deuxième d observation
pour faire mon métier je suis obligé de
juger à sa tante de critères je ne suis
pas quelqu'un qui simplement avec mes
équipes quand je dis moi c'est également
les équipes
valentin le patron des programmes et les
autres je vais vous donner un exemple
extrêmement précis nous avons fait une
émission zone interdite dimanche dernier
qui a eu pas mal de 2,2 de répercussion
sur l'islam radical
cette émission nous avons discuté de
cette émission si vous appelez ça de
l'ingérence c'est à souligner j'étais un
gérant sur cette émission j'ai demandé
si nous avions les garanties si c'était
une émission extrémistes entre
guillemets j'ai demandé si la
présentatrice qui est menacé étaient
protégés j'ai demandé si nous avions les
témoins qui parlait était bien flouté
etc j'ai fait le métier que j'estime
devoir faire sur une émission dont in
fine et la décision mais revenu je la
revendique d'avoir autorisé cette
émission mais parce qu'on me l'a demandé
m'a dit voilà il ya des cette émission
on aurait pu prendre la décision
contraire donc j'estime que c'est mon
devoir de responsabilité alors si vous
appelez ça de la gérance moi j'appelle
ça l'exercice de mon métier sur les
affaires économiques par exemple contre
ingérence
lorsque nous avions le club de bordeaux
je ne souhaitais pas qu'il y ait des
numéros de magazines sur marseille
pourquoi parce qu'on n'aurait soupçonné
à l'époque les
les amateurs de football que ce soit
bordeaux à marseille et neil ancestrale
son sang sont vifs j'ai considéré que
c'était c'était pas notre notre n'était
pas correct de se servir entre 13,1 des
antennes pour alimenter cette polémique
al'inverse
lorsque nous avons fait le sujet sur
amazon amazon est à nos grands clients
nous ont fait un sujet sur amazon sur
des invendus ce sujet a mené un projet
de loin une loin que vous avez voté sur
le devenir des invendus qui étaient
jetés que nous avons fait avec un avec
des moyens tout à fait important là
dessus
récemment nous avons fait une émission
qui était plutôt anti éoliennes nous
avons un parent qui est sur les énergies
et le yen donc je veux bien qu'on dise
une déclaration ceci moi je donne des
faits et si je complète parce qu'elle
vous pourrez peut-être qu'on pose la
question je me suis opposé un jour à ce
que jean pierre pernaut soit alité rtl
bon j'aime beaucoup jean pierre pernaut
j'ai considéré que jusqu'à présent
xavier de moulins nous étions opposés
eux n'avaient pas été invités à tf1 donc
je me suis dit dans un souci d'équilibré
je ne vois pas l'utilité d'inviter jean
pierre pernaut à rtl voilà si c'est ça
mon droit d'ingérence sur lequel il peut
être reprocher je l'assumé
s'il vous plaît juste je dernière
question que je n'ai pas une dernière
question c'est c'est juste une relance
pour une réponse à ma question j'ai pas
porter de jugement général j'ai cité des
faits vous m'avez pas dit si si vous
regrettez avoir tenu ces propos que
c'est des propos d' ingérence l'aca ne
rentrent pas dans les cases que vous
venez de me dire que je comprends que un
responsable d'une antenne et bien se
penche sur un reportage sur l'islamisme
radical ses conséquences comme en quoi
comme on gère derrière mais là il
s'agissait justement de ce problème que
vous avoir toutes les rédactions
si elles ne peuvent pas enquêter sur des
clients potentiels de la maison ou un
fournisseur de publicités alors elles
ont des champs d'investigation qui
réduisent leur liberté j'ai cité deux
chaussures orange j'ai cité free que me
dit vous et vous avez dit aussi dans
télérama vous vous habillez ça de façon
claire
non pas dans télérama dans le nouvelle
économie je considère avoir un droit
d'ingérence
professionnels étant responsable de tout
j'ai le droit d'intervenir surtout
surtout
donc sur l'information et les rédactions
mais c'est répondre cette taverne où je
crois avoir fait une réponse que
j'espère complète monsieur le rapporteur
encore une fois lorsque il y a une je
suis directeur de publication je suis
responsable je défie je vous ai donné
les exemples contraires qui vous montre
la liberté complète qu'il y a dans le
groupe même si c'est un groupe rtl pour
exercer leur métier il y a des dégâts
qui me sont présentés dans lequel je
tranche est par exemple lorsque on fait
une émission que vous avez toute
l'avenue toute la journée une publicité
m6 mobile by orange avec m6 la marque m6
c'est que vous faites un reportage sur
la comparaison entre m6 mobile et free
jeudi que à juste titre je pensais monde
c'est mon mon exercice de ma
responsabilité je pense que personne
imaginera que ceci est objectif voilà et
donc pour la pour la protection de mon
public et pour la protection de l'image
de la chaîne je n'ai pas souhaité
effectivement et ce reportage sur le ct
sur les forfaits bloqués oui je m'en
souviens extrêmement bien je considère
avoir fait mon métier que de préserver
au contraire à linverse l'image du
groupe et je vous ai donné de nombreux
exemples je pourrais vous en donner
encore beaucoup dans lequel au contraire
il ya des reportages qui sont très
défavorables à nos clients
je je je mens tu sais les maisons de
retraite sont même pas nos clients voyez
je veux dire et pour les maisons
retraite avec le livre que nous avons
largement mis en avant sur le groupe
mise en cause donc je crois alors là
franchement on peut poser beaucoup de
questions sur le groupe m6 est il comme
si le groupe et si c'était cela on peut
nous reprocher le loft on peut leur
reprocher un certain nombre de choses en
ce qui concerne l'indépendance des
rédactions en 35 ans d'activité nous
avons suivi la ligne de notre
actionnaire pour mon information et vous
avez dit qu amazon était un de nos
principaux clients c'est en termes de
recettes publicitaires
le le montant des achats très
franchement je n'ai pas en mémoire je
permets moi c'est le message lu à
plusieurs millions d'euros d'accord
sylvie robert
merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur de tavernot
j'aurai trois questions une petite
question annexe mais
alors
en cas de fusion j'aimerais vous
demander quelle sera votre stratégie de
contenus ce qu'on sait que la bataille
se joue à ce niveau là c'est tout à leur
parler beaucoup de synergies et ce qui
aura aussi des mutualisations ce qui
pourrait d'ailleurs à faire des
économies d'échelle mais qui pourrait
appauvrir d'ailleurs la création ou
envisagez-vous vraiment d'accroître
substantiellement le budget alloué aux
contenus audiovisuels pour renforcer
l'ambition du groupe en la matière ça
c'est ma première question
ma deuxième question elle prolonge déjà
un propos que vous avez eue sur gulli en
fait il hier
thomas sera nous a effectivement dit
puisque vous allez devoir céder trois
chaînes hertziennes que vous testiez le
marché
je ne vous demande pas bien sûr quels
sont les trois chaînes et il nous a bien
dit que rien n'était décidé mais j'ai
posé la question sur les critères de
cette en matière de thèse du marché au
delà de la question économique parce que
guy les est une chaîne quand même tout à
fait spécifique vous en avez parlé parce
qu'on a bien senti que ça pose problème
est-ce que vous pouvez approfondir le
sujet et nous dire que finalement vous
aimeriez mais que par rapport à ce qui
se passe c'est difficile
la troisième chose c'est salto là aussi
vous l'avez cité vrai sujet
c'est un petit poucet peu d'abonnés je
compare ça à eau géant que l'on connaît
américain
il y aura une vraie stratégie à adopter
pour ça et au en termes
d'investissements technologie là aussi
jusqu'où voulez-vous aller et est ce que
c'est vraiment l'ambition de ce groupe
de développer cette plateforme de
streaming française et enfin mais vous
avez parlé foot je sais que vous êtes un
amateur de foot
non c'est pas le seul moi aussi tu sais
bien et donc tf1 m6 ce sont des chaînes
qui sont quand même historiquement
engagés dans le monde du foot alors avec
l'éventuelle fusion je vous dis ça est
ce que vous avez envie de re rentrer
dans le jeu des droits télé pour la
ligue des champions la ligue 1 et pour
surtout voilà diffusée en clair une
partie de ces compétitions petit mais
qui seront quand même là aussi vecteur
d'identité pour eux l'éventuelle fusion
si elle se fait merci beaucoup
sur sur les investissements dans la
production et dans la création notre
intention est d'augmenter nos recettes
août et donc comme nous avons des
pourcentages sur le cinéma sur
l'animation sur la fiction il y à une
corrélation entre notre réussite et les
investissements dans la création ça
c'est le premier point la deuxième point
nous souhaitons ardemment
accéléré en streaming ça me rejoint
votre question de salto salto est une
réussite
avec notre collègue gilles pélisson avec
delphine ernotte nous avons mis beaucoup
d'efforts pour que salto soit une régie
n'était pas commode c'était pas commode
c'était une bombe simplement il ya une
limite nous sommes concurrents essaient
du core business le pardon de m'exprimer
ainsi le streaming est ce qu'on les met
en avant c'est ce qu'on l'aimé or après
nos programmes est ce qu'on l'aimé avec
de la pub est ce qu'on l'aimé sans pub
et c'est une des raisons de la fusion
avec la fusion nous serons beaucoup plus
libres d'unir nos forces pour développer
de la fumée dans une poétique de
streaming beaucoup plus ambitieuse qui
avec des contenus locaux des contenus
français permettront de développer salto
sur la question de la cession des
chaînes pardon
que des france télévisions a manifesté
il a dit publiquement je crois le
souhait que si la fusion se faisaient de
sortir de salto pour ne pas se retrouver
minoritaire de deux actionnaires qui qui
serait à ce moment là réunis nous sommes
tout à fait ouverts à discuter avec
france télévisions pour sûr sur ce point
français vision est un bon partenaire
delphine ernotte et très efficace dans
le temps dans la dans la défense de
salto
c'est pour répondre à monsieur assouline
que je trouve qu'il ya des gens de
compétences dans le service public et
simplement c'est vrai qu'elle peut se
retrouver en minoritaire dans un
ensemble qui est plus important et donc
elle a manifesté son intention de
regarder examiner la situation dans ce
cas là et nous sommes ouverts évidemment
à l'examen de cette situation en ce qui
concerne la cession des chaînes
premièrement c'est un déchirement que
posséder des chaînes vraiment et si
législation pouvait bouger sur ce point
nous en serions extrêmement heureux
malheureusement nous sommes dans un
cadre du state pardon
omeyer et pas de tnt donc c'est normal
qu'elle s'adapte deuxièmement on n'a pas
eu de canal compensatoire enfin bref on
va pas refaire l'histoire en tous les
cas c'est un déchirement pour nous de
céder des chaînes que nous avons créés
ou que nous avons racheté développé que
ce soit je pense mon collègue gilles
pélisson vous dira la même chose pour de
sa part ou que ce soit pour m6 avec des
collaborateurs avec des collègues qui
ont travaillé de manière efficace donc
nous avons d'abord une dit synergie
comment dire sur l'opération de fusion
et c'est regrettable
donc nous allons choisir la meilleure
combinaison entre les candidats qui sont
acquéreurs puisqu'il faut des candidats
qu'ils soient motivés nous avons des
candidats y compris pour les chaînes
jeunesse simplement ces candidats sont
plus limités pour les limitations je
vous ai indiqué est donc de notre point
de vue c'est maladroit parce que je
pense que quand il ya une association
producteurs diffuseurs tout le monde est
gagnant
tout le monde est gagnant et que
notamment dans le domaine de l'animation
c'est très important je viens à
l'instant dans le domaine de l'animation
parce qu'il ya un point que je voudrais
dire qu'elle est très important
aujourd'hui par exemple les fabricants
de jouets internationaux
aujourd'hui ils font du placement de
produit sur les plateformes
internationales en dix ans j'aurais une
audience internationale je peux passer
de la pub est ainsi je jeu donc nous
nous devons absolument participer à la
production parce que à travers les
placements produits sinon nous serons
totalement contourner
donc c'est des productions
internationales qui vont se développer
il y aura pas de production française
donc pour nous c'est absolument
fondamental que d'avoir ces
regroupements
merci président bonjour monsieur
tavernot
le groupe socialiste nous écologistes et
républicains nous propose un thème de
commission denquête
qui est à double entrée
et si je relis mettre en lumière les
processus ayant permis ou pouvant
aboutir à une concentration dans les
médias en france
est évalué l'impact de cette
concentration dans une démocratie est
invariablement depuis le début de ces
auditions
on passe de l'un à l'autre je ne vais
pas dire dans un dialogue de sourds mais
je pense qu'il faut y aller et on peut
déjà
ressortir des choses comme disait
boileau ce qui se conçoit bien s'énonce
clairement et les mots pour le dire
arrivent aisément tous les entrepreneurs
que nous avons auditionné depuis le
début
il comprit y compris les dirigeants des
structures publiques
y compris certains journalistes tout le
monde a répondu à cette première
question en disant que la concentration
au relève du niveau économique que sur
sauf à se voiler les yeux à ne pas
regarder la réalité ce qui s'impose aux
dirigeants y compris donc monsieur rabe
qui est étranger à notre pays même s'il
ya des liens et qu'ils maîtrisent la
langue française mais est venu nous dire
avec une espèce de d'évidence combien en
termes économiques aujourd'hui
l'opération vous entreprenez même s'il
va falloir quand même 18 mois alors un
petit peu moins maintenant mais sait on
voit que c'est un parcours du combattant
donc c'est absolument encadré d'une
façon
stricte estime on voit bien que c'est en
fait un sujet d'abord d'économies
maintenant la deuxième question elle est
un peu plus compliqué parce que celle là
elle nous amène à notre sacro sainte
démocratie
donc moi j'ai juste quelques questions à
vous poser c'est dans un système d'une
incroyable rigidité comme vous l'avez
soulié tout à l'heure comment peut-on
assurer une certaine étanchéité entre
les actionnaires et je parle bien des
actionnaires et pas des dirigeants parce
que là sinon je ne vois pas comment une
entreprise peut fonctionner donc
l'étanchéité entre les actionnaires et
la démocratie ma deuxième question
beaucoup s'inquiètent à raison du poids
de ce que va représenter l'ensemble tf1
m6 ne pensez vous pas
que pour équilibrer ce nouveau groupe il
serait légitime que la puissance
publique au lieu d'avoir un carcan et et
d'or justement renforcer ce carcan la
puissance publique pourrait encourager
l'émergence d'un second groupe privé qui
pourrait peser 15 à 20% du marché et
quels seraient les moyens de favoriser
cette évolution notamment sur le plan
réglementaire
merci de me de ces questions sur le plan
économique n'est pas différent du reste
gelée soulignait tout à l'heure que la
création c'est aussi une affaire de cash
flow l'information c'est une affaire de
moyens le développement de nos
entreprises si nous nous trouvons
confrontés à des systèmes étrangers
d'information unique et que
progressivement nous avons des moyens
qui diminue nous serons en grande
difficulté et compris sur le plan
démocratique
je pense que nous faisons une
information de qualité
et que cette information de qualité est
nécessaire dans une démocratie
elle n'est pas orientée elle essaie
d'être le plus indépendante possible je
crois que que ce soit en matière de
radio où que ce soit en matière de
télévision le groupe m6 a fait la preuve
de son indépendance je ne vois pas
comment elle pourrait être remise en
cause j'en profite pour dire que
l'actionnariat oui la séparation entre
l'actionnaire et les dirigeants c'est
une séparation qui n'est pas une
séparation juridique puisque le
dirigeant et responsable comme l'a
rappelé monsieur assouline devant les
actionnaires
simplement le dirigeant il a une mission
qui est de développer son entreprise sur
la base d'un cahier des charges qui est
extrêmement précis donné par le csa et
je pense qu'il faut aussi
faire confiance
à l'historique
lorsque vous avez deux actionnaires tels
qu'ils se sont présentés devant vous ou
qui vont se présenter devant vous qui
ont un historique d'indépendance qui
automne à nice éric de confiance dans
leur management
quand vous regardez il ya eu que quatre
présidents je crois y compris ce week
dans l'histoire de tf1 nous en avons
connu deux dans l'histoire de m6 jean
drucker et moi même ce sont des gens qui
ne sont pas là pour le court terme ce
sont des gens qui investissent et ce
sont des gens qui font confiance donc je
pense que cet historique devrait être de
nature à rassurer
en ce qui concerne l' équilibre des
groupes l'equilibre des groupes nous
avons un grand groupe public qui est de
loin le plus important en france que ce
soit par le nombre de journalistes que
ce soit par le nombre de de
deux chaînes que ce soit par les moyens
qui lui sont alloués par la puissance
publique
nous avons un groupe disons autour de la
télévision payante que vous avez
l'occasion d'auditionner ce matin et
nous avons un groupe qui serait au tour
de la télévision gratuite principalement
dont deux groupes privés avec des zones
de concurrence assez forte d'ailleurs
deux groupes privés je pense que dans l'
équilibre modernes tels que ceux se
présenta concurrence internationale
c'est un paysage qui est des gens
concurrentiel et regardez bien quelles
sont les regroupements qui se fond dans
tous les domaines de consolidation là
nous discutons paisiblement mais pendant
ce temps là vous avez des regroupements
gigantesque fox et disney netflix vient
de s'installer à hollywood sont co sion
vous avez des organisations et
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de frontières
des ardennes pour l'audiovisuel français
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à ces
gens là qui sont plutôt avantagé dans la
réglementation qui leur est imposé il ne
signe pas toujours les engagements qui
leur sont donnés confère la chronologie
des médias récemment ou deux des grands
des plus grandes plateformes n'ont pas
signé cet accord qu'il aurait pour tous
très favorable d'ailleurs donc
aujourd'hui le regroupement pardon de le
dire comme ça tf1 m6 paraît une évidence
c'est une évidence et une force et moi
permettez moi de donner une opinion
personnelle j'étais très heureux de la
confiance que que martin bouygues et et
le groupe bertelsmann le donne et que
cette confiance à mon âge j'aurais pu me
retirer disons mission accomplie sur le
groupe m6 il est en bonne santé il se
développe il ya de nombreuses chaînes il
a pas une mauvaise image il a une radio
qui fonctionne bien si j'ai souhaité
continuer et avoir la confiance de deux
actionnaires c'est parce que je
considère que la mission n'est pas si 10
et que c'est le plus important qui reste
à faire c'est cette consolidation ceux
qui refuseraient cette conciliation
prendrait un grand risque dans
l'audiovisuel français je le dis
solennellement devant votre commission
car aujourd'hui face à ces plateformes
face à la concurrence internationale
face à la concentration de la production
le premier producteur de fiction en
france et haïti vit studio je le dis
bien à itv studios qui n'est d'ailleurs
plus dans l'europe
et je je je dis comprendrait une énorme
responsabilité et que aujourd'hui avec
les règles qui nous sont imposées avec
les conventions qui sont sous la
responsabilité du csa je pense qu'il n'y
a pas de risque dans ce métier de
concentration
c'est un point important que vous
souvenir si cette fusion ne se faisait
pas ça sera un grand risque pour le dieu
de l'audiovisuel
le problème c'est que ça ne va pas être
regarder uniquement par rapport à la
pertinence sur le secteur audiovisuel
mais par rapport à la notion de marché
pertinent en matière publicitaire est ce
que
vous avez bien analyser
l'impact que pourrait avoir une lecture
juridique uniquement de cette notion de
marché pertinence si la décision vous
était défavorable quelles seraient les
conséquences pour les deux à la fois tf1
et m6 j'ai d'abord nous nous mettons
dans une version optimiste nous
discutons avec la dlc
de l'analyse de ce marché et permettez
moi de vous dire qu'aujourd'hui tous les
facteurs sont en faveur d'une analyse
ouverte je pense que ici vous avez
entendu tous les facteurs alors que
certains veulent protéger à court terme
une rente sort on peut le comprendre que
ce soit dans des domaines de concurrence
de production etc je dis simplement que
lorsque vous regardez la dynamique des
marchés
c'est en 2016 que monsieur c'est tout a
dit que le digital et est devenu le
premier média est donc aujourd'hui nous
avons les mêmes annonceurs nous avons
souvent les mêmes publicités sur tik tok
sur facebook sur instagram sûr et si on
veut donner tout notre marché et nous
nous avons besoin de nous regrouper pour
avoir être plus efficace en
programmation ça c'est une un élément
très important
d'investir beaucoup plus dans dans le
domaine de notre offre adapter notre
offre à nos besoins et
arrêté sept 7 cette descente de la
baisse de la durée d'écouté de la
télévision traditionnelle nous devons la
compenser par une écoute de streaming et
nous offre nous offriront ainsi au
marché des occasions d'annoncé alors on
peut dire en 2000 en 2021 2022 nous
avons des gros écran alors d'abord 90%
de la publicité n'est pas sur les écrans
important nous avons une position
dominante sur le marché parce 70% nous
représentons 70% du marché net je dis
que c'est une vue tout à fait biaisée à
faire parce que beaucoup de nos clients
et si vous les interrogez
l'arbitrage est constant les grands
groupes aujourd'hui font un arbitrage
constant entre le digital et la
télévision est aujourd'hui
le digital a repris l'aventage la
croissance du digital et et enfin tous
les vous aurez les chiffres 2021 qui
vont sortir la semaine prochaine vous
verrez le taux de croissance de la
publicité à la télévision versus le taux
de croissance de la publicité digitale
ces chiffres seront publics la semaine
prochaine je crois vous verrez que si on
se projette dans un an dans deux ans
dans trois ans dans cinq ans les cours
vont en fait c'est un peu comme si on
disait entre la presse écrite il ya dix
ans donc nous c'est le syndrome de la
presse écrite nous ne voulons pas être
comme la presse écrite ne pas avoir vu
les mutations alors certains journaux
sont très bien adaptés c'est parce que
je veux dire mais nous voulons avoir la
possibilité nous adapter et la
concentration de nos moyens en france
est un petit marché à l'échelle
internationale et on peut pas avoir la
double critique qui est en vous êtes
trop vous êtes trop petit pour lutter
contre les gars fans mais vous êtes trop
gros parce que vous allez mettre à bas
l'audiovisuel français
nous nous avons un juste milieu nous
pensons que en matière locales en
matière locale nous pouvons rivaliser
avec les plateformes et avoir un contenu
original comme le font les allemands il
vous a expliqué thomas sera bugs et
investissent beaucoup dans le streaming
avec des produits locaux nick de barco
bonjour messieurs de tallano je reviens
un petit peu sur
les questions que pose et ma collègue
sylvie robert
avec des auditions que nous avons eu la
semaine dernière avec la sacem et la
scam ceux ci ont exprimé leur inquiétude
pourquoi parce que le comprend pour ces
tf1 m6 aurait davantage de force d'après
eux pourtant de le bras ou des sociétés
d'auteurs et poussée des prix à la
baisse
c'était la vision qu'elle garantit plus
et vous apporter aux auteurs et aux
sociétés qu'ils représentent c'est ma
première question jeanne est une autre
qui concerne aussi salto je suis abonné
à salto
toulon le sait
cependant et vous vous allez pas
d'accord non mais parce que
mais je ne suis pas seulement abonnés
casal tôt non je n'ai certains
noms dans votre introduction vous avez
surtout parlé des freins rencontrés
par principalement par la dlc
- et anggun abonné je m'interroge acquis
qu'elle le marché le seul toit qui
s'adresse parce que j'aime pas le
divertissement j'aime pas la télé
réalité
j'aimerais bien pouvoir enregistrer le
catalogue n'est pas assez complet à mon
goût quand on est à l'étranger on ne
peut pas visionné salto
je trouve que l'interface n'est pas
performante n'est pas convivial je suis
abonnée aussi à molotov j'apprécie
beaucoup la façon de pouvoir et sur
molotov et c'est intuitif
pensez vous les faire évoluer salto
justement pour que ce soit plus comme on
y reste plus performant plus aguichante
plus attractif aussi ce son contenu et
sur son interface
alors sur sur la question de salto 1
vous êtes parmi les presque 500 mille
abonnés donc il y en a pas qu'un
donc donc
je considère que compte tenu de ses
contraintes c'est un succès il ya une
très bonne équipe sur sur salto le les
développements techniques ont été faits
c'est une c'est une affaire compliquée
c'est une affaire complexe et justement
quand vous savez que netflix investi un
milliard d'euros dans la technologie
vous voyez bien nous nous avons regroupé
nos forces autour d'une société qui
s'appelle bedrock justement pour comme
vous l'expliqué thomas sera buzz pour
développer et mutualiser un certain
nombre de fonctions des plateformes
c'est pas parfait et surtout en tant que
concurrent nous ne pouvons pas donner
tous nos programmes pour le streaming et
arbitrer entre ce que nous mettons en
avant ce qui fait partie de l'écosystème
de nos propres programmes c'est
horriblement compliqué pour les équipes
de salto d'offrir un produit très
homogène tels qu'ils existent parce que
nous sommes en compétition sur la
télévision gratuite
les uns avec les autres je pense que
grâce à la fusion nous pourrons avoir un
produit beaucoup plus moderne beaucoup
plus ambitieux et avec une ambition de
je pense que j'ai payé sans vous le
confirmera lors de son audition une
ambition d'investissement extrêmement
fort donc c'est un très gros enjeu pour
nous et je remercie de l'avoir de
l'avoir souligné en ce qui concerne les
droits d'auteur
en matière de monopole je pense pas que
il est de leçon à recevoir de nous
il y a nous sommes confrontés donc à des
difficultés inter droit sociétés
d'auteurs
il se trouve que la sacem voudrait
continuer à nous qualifier de chaînes
musicales alors que nous faisons plus de
fictions donc cette répartition comme on
dit un terreau social est complexe nous
ce que nous avons simplement dit c'est
que nous ne voulons pas payer plus cher
en tôt que ce que nous payons
aujourd'hui pour la somme des trois
sociétés d'auteurs donc il ya une
discussion entre ces sociétés d'auteurs
j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas de la part
notamment de la sacem d'abus de position
dominante je l'espère et nous sommes
toujours en discussion et nous sommes
ouverts et nous avons payé régulièrement
pendant 35 ans nos droits d'auteur il ya
un renouvellement de contrat ce
renouvellement de contrat fait que nous
espérons que nous arrivions un équilibre
entre les deux parties en tous les cas
c'est notre volonté car nous n'avons
aucune difficulté avec les auteurs
vous pourriez nous nous éclaircir sur ce
point parce que la csn et qu'ils aient
un conflit avec vous sur des droits
d'auteur que vous ne payez pas est ce
que vous pourriez nous donner une
réponse
notre contrat arrivait à échéance le 31
décembre de cette année c'était un
contrat collectif collective qui
rassemblait les trois sociétés d'auteurs
ces sociétés parfois de manière
justifiée comme les cds nous ont fait
savoir que elle souhaitait que cette
répartition qu'il y ait trois contrats
séparés que cette répartition souhaite
différentes à partir de trois contrats
séparés nous on a discuté avec lui on
s'est aperçu que la somme des trois
était beaucoup plus importante que ce
que nous payons globalement la gamme
donc on a commencé à entamer des
discussions avec chacune d'entre elles
je dois dire que la position de la sacem
et la plus rigide en nous disant en nous
disant voilà le tarif et vous signez en
bas à droite
c'est pas dans les habitudes de la
maison donc donc nous aurons encore
quelques discussions s'il faut une
médiation nous nous proposerons une
médiation le csa souvent se propose
comme médiateur s'il faut avoir une
juridiction il y aura une juridiction
nous payons nous avons proposé à la
sacem de maître par anticipation les
sommes bloquées que nous payons avant
sur nos contrats pour montrer que nous
voulons continuer à payer les auteurs
sur la base de ce que nous payons
précédemment et nous espérons qu'entre
temps les négociations continuent go il
y aura une position qui sera équilibré
entre les parties prenantes mais notre
intention n'est pas d'avoir une rupture
avec les sociétés d'auteurs michel
logique
merci monsieur le président c'est un
verre d'eau merci déjà de toutes les
informations quinté donner parce que ces
tueries fissiles de pas son dernier
beaucoup de questions ont été posées non
mais j'aimerais revenir un petit peu sur
l'origine de la fusion et le contexte
dans lequel vous aviez au visage et ces
choses là
dans un couple quand on est mariés ont
dit qu'un consentement mutuel mais
je veux savoir qui a fait le premier pas
entre tf1 et m6 et surtout est-ce que
vous aviez le choix de vous rapprocher
d'autres ou parce que vous avez expliqué
que pour vous face heures
aujourd'hui à l'évolution du paysage
médiatique
il fallait changer de stratégie dont est
ce que vous aviez le choix de vous
rapprocher d'autres groupes à vous avez
vous d'autres propositions ça c'est ma
première question la deuxième et vous
l'avez me tu peux évoquer les jeunes et
j'aimerais que vous allez un petit peu
plus loin sur l'avenir parce que pendant
que vous travaillez une fusion pendant
ce temps il ya des plateformes
intéressante qui se renforce j'allais
dire parce que de jour en jour parce que
ça va vraiment très vite vous avez parlé
du digital et justement
si on se penche déjà dans l'étape
d'après
comment vous voyez votre renforcement
dans les années à venir est-ce que ça va
être encore à travers des fusions des
rachats ou est-ce que vous allez être
encore plus imaginatifs je ne sais pas
peut-être vous allez me répondre et puis
d'interrogation on a parlé beaucoup de
football
vous avez parlé du club des girondins de
bordeaux vous a parlé de marseille je
rappelle que marseille s'est imposé à
bordeaux il ya quelques jours pour la
première fois depuis 44 ans mais c'est
parce que je veux vous dire tout
simplement simplement vous indiquez est
ce qu'aujourd'hui
est ce que aujourd'hui avec le nouveau
groupe vous allez diriger est ce que
vous seriez intéressé pour vous
rapprocher ou pour prendre en gestion de
football professionnel français
je commencerai si vous voulez bien par
votre première votre dernière question
1 de notre temps nous avons passé 19 ans
à bordeaux marseille n'a jamais gagné à
bordeaux
je tiens à préciser ce point là
voilà merci de lui avoir tendu nous
sommes malheureux que ceci soit arrivé
cette année la deuxième chose nous
sommes sortis du football après 19 ans
parce que nous n'avions plus les moyens
à consacrer suffisamment à bordeaux nous
estimions que le contenu du nouveau
périmètre qui avait avec notamment
l'arrivée des qataris le psg etc nous ne
pouvons plus suivre ce ceci et que ce
n'était pas dans notre corps de métier
d'où nous en sommes sortis je doute que
nous y revenir
en ce qui concerne la fusion et vous
avez raison de dire qui se sera passé
probablement deux ans entre le moment où
se sont faits les discussions et le
moment où la société serait opérationnel
la nouvelle société serait très très
long c'est très long nous avons au moins
trois autorités la mf l'art comme la dlc
et avec les toutous toute la procédure
qui va avec lé renouvellement
d'autorisation des sessions de chêne qui
doivent être agréés qui doivent être
autorisées je n'ai rarement vu un
dossier aussi complexe qui
s'enchevêtrent qui se bousculent et donc
nous avons choisi la crète pour non non
non dans cette affaire
alors qui a eu le qui a fait le premier
pas je dirais qu'il ya eu un pas très
important qui a été fait par rtl groupe
bertelsmann c'est comme vous voulez a
expliqué thomas sera beau hier c'est
d'accepter que ce soit un groupe
français qui est le contrôle exclusif de
l'ensemble
c'est ce pas qui a été le déclencheur de
l'opération avec mon collègue gilles
pélisson nous avions souvent évoqué
cette possibilité de nous de rassembler
nos forces alors que nous sommes très
concurrentes jour d'hui nous voyons bien
l'évolution du marché simplement tant
que rtl group n'acceptait pas de
d'abandonner son contrôle exclusif sur
l'ensemble
mais il n'y avait pas de possibilité car
nous le savions
1 il était logique que ce soit un
français qui soit rencontrer l'ex élu de
cette opération et je pense que c'était
l'intention du groupe boeing d'avoir ce
contrôle exclusif donc c'est ce
déclenchement qui est si j'ose dire le
premier pain dans dans la fusion alors
sur le temps et pendant ce temps là en
fait on développe pas suffisamment les
choses alors deux choses premièrement
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
période de fiançailles mais nous avons
pas le droit de consommer
donc la consommation ne viendra qu'après
le 15 janvier si l'opération se fait
c'est frustrant et la deuxième chose
nous gérons nos entreprises dans un
climat de concurrence mais nous
investissons six plaies nous le
développons le cinéma j'en ai parlé la
production nous essayons d'en faire le
plus possible donc nous développons nos
groupes dans une compétition jusqu'à ce
que nous recevions l'autorisation et que
nous puissions procéder au vote en
assemblée générale de cette fusion
et de line renaud garabédian
evelyne vous ne m'entendez
elle est derrière son écran
vrai et cognac jury
voilà
merci monsieur le président monsieur de
tableau vous vous êtes montré très
critique sur la règlementation française
qui impose aux diffuseurs une
contribution à la production d'oeuvres
audiovisuelles
indexé sotchi d'affaires des chaînes en
cas de fusion et fin m6 quelle sera la
position de nouvel ensemble vis-à-vis de
la création audiovisuelle et du
financement de celles-ci je pense de sa
vente aux petits producteurs
indépendants qui sont aux cigales du
pluralisme une autre petite question
pouvez vous revenir en détail sur le
débat relatif à la publicité télévisée
versus la publicité numérique et quelles
conséquences cela at-il sur votre
activité merci de vos réponses
merci sur la production indépendante
nous sommes très favorables à la
production indépendante et je le dirai
d'autant plus qu' énormément de gens de
chez nous on
je viens de chez nous à monter leur
propre entreprise
emmanuel chain a monté les champs thomas
anargyros est l'un des dirigeants les
plus importants de média one et donc ils
se sont installés et ont développé à
partir de leur expérience des sociétés
et lorsque on nous donne de bonnes idées
nous ne refuserons jamais un programme
lorsque ce programme sera utile pour
notre pour notre groupe et souvent la
production indépendante développe des
programmes qui sont utiles pour notre
groupe que ce soit en flux ou que ce
soit en stock ou en fiction et en ce qui
concerne l'information nous faisons
travailler énormément de deux sociétés
d' agences de presse de poing dont je
parlais des samoa décale tout honneur
c'est un une production tony comiti qui
est une des grosses agences de presse de
la place de paris donc nous n'avons pas
de difficulté avec la foi du char
dépendantes nous voulons simplement que
nous puissions nous associer à des
producteurs ce que nous ne pouvons pas
faire aujourd'hui ou insuffisamment
faire pour
pour pouvoir développer de la production
comme le font tous les diffuseurs et les
producteurs dans le monde ont voulu
envoyer sont tous appuyé sur des grandes
sources de pollution donc ça c'est ma
première marque pas deuxième remarque
c'est que les obligations production
elles sont tantôt et nous ne contestons
pas ses taux donc ce que je dis c'est
que ni si nous augmentons nos recettes
nous avons les 3 5% ou 3% sur le cinéma
nous allons probablement signé j'espère
un accord si les mains nous avons
l'animation 1% nous avons la production
audiovisuelle la production patrimoniale
tout ça est encadrée dans les
conventions et nous le remettrons
évidemment pas en cause ces conventions
et en ce qui concerne votre deuxième
question sur la publicité digitale
versus la publicité
télévisée kung avoir répondu à la
question nous avons une évolution très
rapide de la publicité à la télévision
j'en profite pour dire que dans la
réglementation nous voulons une défense
de la tnt c'est très important la tnt
d'abord aller gratuite deuxièmement elle
va sur tous les territoires et je sais
que le sénat ait enfin il est sensible
et enfin je dirais que sur la tnt nous
pouvons faire avec les téléviseurs
connectés de la publicité a dit adressé
comme nous pouvons le faire sur les box
nous souhaitons une normalisation de la
norme hbbtv comme l'ont fait les
allemands pour pouvoir développer la
publicité adressée à partir de la tnt
enfin je voudrais je ne manquerai pas de
répondre que nous avons un comité
d'éthique sur l'information pour
rassurer qui auraient quelques ce comité
d'éthique d'ailleurs est présidé par un
ancien sénateur
donc c'est sûr 20 est garantie de
sérieux est ce ce comité d'éthique n'a
jamais je pense amy de difficultés avec
les rapports c'est de cette bourse ya
avec les rapports nous avons un comité
d'éthique qui fonctionne correctement
depuis deux ans et demi en fait depuis
qu'il a été mise en place et il a eu à
chaque fois chacun peut le saisir comme
une souhaité nous n'avons jamais eu de
difficulté qui a été soulevée par notre
comité d'éthique
laurence harribey
laurence
on nous entend pas
je pense que le micro n'est pas branché
bon c'est bon excusez moi ça y est
j'aurai une je voudrais me permettre de
revenir sur une sur une question qui a
été posée à la fois par sylvie robert et
mémé qui quittera ans avec un peu plus
de
deux heures indépendamment du fait
d'être propriétaire d'un club
on a compris que le sport dans les
précédentes auditions que le sport était
un élément important du point de vue
stratégique pour les groupes de médias
et j'aurais voulu vous vous interrogez
sur le fait est ce que vous pensez que
le modèle économique des droits télé
peut remettre en cause la présence des
grands médias français lors de grandes
de grands événements sportifs
on nous a dit par exemple la ligue des
champions roland garros c'était des
éléments fondamentaux dans dans
l'attractivité d'un certain nombre de
chaînes est ce que est ce que c'est ça
remet en cause ce nouveau modèle de
diffusion avec les droits télé et on
voit la puissance montante d'un des
plateformes et en particulier amazon
dans le dans ce secteur-là et puis une
deuxième petite question
quand quand on parle de production
indépendante est ce que vous avez une
approche stratégique par rapport aux
multitudes de petites sociétés qui se
fonde sa multitude c'est peut-être un
peu exagéré
s'ils ont des caractères un caractère
plutôt régionaliste et thématiques et
est-ce que vous avez une approche
stratégique de ces éléments là merci
merci madame pour votre question de
remarques sur le sport le sport et le
pétrole de la télévision payante ou des
plateformes demain c'est la raison pour
laquelle les événements protéger et la
liste des événements protégé est
fondamental pour nous et nous remercions
législateur de s'est emparé cette
question car il protège ainsi de l'accès
au sport et aux grands événements le
public
la raison l'une des raisons de la fusion
et de pouvoir nous donner des moyens
d'avoir plus de moyens pour avoir des
événements sportifs sur nos antennes
nous serons plus forts pour mettre des
événements sportifs de manière en accès
gratuit sur les plates formes sur les
sur m6 tf1 que nous le sommes nous le
sommes actuellement ça c'est une
ça sera un élément important de notre de
notre activité en ce qui concerne la
création et notamment les sociétés
régionales avant nous faisons déjà
travaillé je crois que c'est d'ailleurs
le cas pour tf1 de quelques-unes qui
sont communes des agences d'information
régionale nous avons des correspondants
avec des sociétés qui sont généralement
souvent adossées d'ailleurs un journal
régional nous avons des correspondances
qui nous font beaucoup de sujets dans
nos journaux télévisés avec lequel nous
avons de bons rapports par ailleurs nous
sommes très attachés nous avoir beaucoup
d'éléments sur ce qu'on appelle la
province et je vous donnerai un seul
exemple dans le cinéma nous avons sorti
les beaux dunks est un film un peu
surprenant puisque il n'a fait aucune
entrée à paris et qu'il a fait 1 million
600 mille entrées en province avec son
spectacle tiré du spectacle et vaud
l'ain donc nous sommes très attachés
également à la bien couvrir l'activité
en province
comment interprétez-vous l'attitude du
groupe iliad qui est possède l'opérateur
free on le sait et qui a l'air assez
remonté sur le projet de fusion tf1 m6
et qui envisagent de saisir la
commission européenne
prétendant que ce n'est pas aux
autorités françaises de de traiter ce
dossier je croise présent que vous aurez
l'occasion d'en voir son propriétaire et
donc de lui poser directement la
question nous avons des rapports à la
fois de client à fournisseur sur dans
double sens avec le groupe free iliad à
la fois nous avons la publicité pour ces
la téléphonie et en même temps nous lui
fournissons des chaînes et services pour
son réseau voilà ce que je peux dire je
peux dire simplement que le groupe iliad
en tous les cas à travers son
propriétaire est un groupe extrêmement
puissant dans les médias
donc notamment à travers la presse à
travers des nouveaux des nouveaux
services notamment de streaming
l'information est donc peut-être
aurait-il voulu se renforcer je ne sais
pas elle voulu poser la question mais
c'est le rapporteur
je n'ai pas le souvenir que vous mais
répondu avec précision à une question
concernant le le maintien des rédactions
de l'ensemble des entités qui vont
fusionner il y à des entités qui sont
dans le même domaine à télévision lci
tf1 m6 il y à une radio
rtl et donc je
me loin que vous faisiez
un petit peu
près ce que mon terme d'engagement
céleyran tous les cas de façon précise 6
et ses rédactions sont bien maintenues
qu'il n'y a pas de dégraissage à
l'occasion ni de fusion des rédactions
et puis ensuite
cette question est étayée par un souci
particulier qui donnerait le mauvais
signe on assiste déjà à une mise en
commun des antennes de rtl et m6 pour
l'émission du les courbes et en fin de
matinée est ce que c'est pour cela que
je vous rends pression parce que ça
donne une tendance puisque
est-ce qu'on doit s'attendre à ce que la
fusion conduisent à renforcer cette
tendance à la mutualisation des moyens
principalement au sein des rédactions
à la manière de ce que peut réaliser
nextradiotv en son temps avec la mise en
commun des rédactions de rmc bfm tv
c'est un modèle qui
oui avec précision sur ces questions en
ce qui concerne ma partie mais je
rappelle que c'est le crew défunt qui
doit notifier les remèdes auprès de la
dlc en tant que contrôleur exclusif
futures du groupe et donc je ne peux
répondre que pour partir aux réponses
mais je crois que à l'occasion de
visionner e gilles léger son jeu sur wii
je vous dirais quelque principe sur
lequel nous sommes mis d'accord
le premier principe c'est qu'il y aura
une autonomie des rédactions une
autonomie des réactions ça veut dire
quoi c'est à dire qu'il ya un directeur
de rédaction par support comme nous
l'avons fait aujourd'hui avec les là
aussi le nom sur le rapporteur c'est de
regarder l'expérience que nous faisons
aujourd'hui il ya eu quelques quelques
disons mouvement quand nous avons
racheté rtl
aujourd'hui le groupe rtl a son
autonomie rédactionnelle parce que la
radio c'est pas la télé et nous avons
deux directeurs de rédaction qui sont
l'un à la télé l'autre alan est ce que
ça veut dire qu'on ne fait pas des
choses ensemble ça serait absurde nous
faisons même des choses aujourd'hui et
qu'elle sait y le grand jury rtl est
fait avec lci et donc nous continuerons
à faire des choses j'ai cité al banna
turin tout à l'heure à l'occasion de la
venue de monsieur marché
aujourd'hui
si vous nous dites fusionner c'est à
dire pour reprendre l'analogie vous avez
le droit de vous marier mais vous de
leychert chambres séparées pendant toute
votre vie on n'ira pas ses 7,7 c'est
très clair nous avons besoin nous
d'avoir des synergies qui sont
mutuellement profitable aujourd'hui nous
avons des collaborations je dis bien des
collaborations entre les rédactions qui
fonctionne extrêmement bien par exemple
nous avions besoin d'un présentateur sur
le journal de m6 pendant les fêtes
pendant les congés des présenter or
actuel et un présentateur qui en plus de
son métier de journaliste à rtl est venu
présenter avec beaucoup d'efficacité
d'ailleurs le journal de 19h45 il en est
je crois très heureux nous en sommes
très heureux le public en est très
heureux
so what voilà donc
ceci fonctionne vous me parlez de
l'émission de julien courbet elle ne
s'est jamais aussi bien porté en radios
jamais aussi bien porté en radios et
elle nous a ajouté de l'audience on
télévision d'ailleurs on fait très
attention à la particularité des deux
supports c'est pas tout à fait elle
commence pas la même heure en radio en
télévision il ya des spécificités à la
radio et nous avons des troncs communs
pour en faire la promotion c'est
exactement c'est un modèle je pense
extrêmement vertueux indépendance
éditoriale
1 chaque métier respecter parce que la
radio c'est pas la télé on vous le savez
est par contre des communautés de moyens
nous pouvons avoir par exemple un
correspondant c'est ce qu'il craint
d'ailleurs qui vient m6 pour rtl aux
états unis ça marche très bien ça marche
très bien et le correspondent aux états
unis il est plutôt content d'avoir à
faire de la radio de la télévision ça
lui donne de la notoriété et c'est donc
très franchement je je je vois pas le
sujet qui est d'aider des questions je
crois on nous a répondu sur
l'actionnaire à ce que l'actionnaire
intervient dans les rédactions la
réponse est non le train gris comme le
montre est ce que les dirigeants
intervient dans la rédaction nous
faisons notre métier de responsable de
directeur de publication est-ce que les
rédactions sont autonomes par rapport à
chacun des supports la réponse est oui
juste une précision pour une question de
mes collègues
tout à l'heure
vous a demandé qui a fait le premier pas
mais disons est ce qu'il ya eu d'autres
offres de rachat
permettez moi de vous faire la même
réponse que thomas sera un peu plus loin
qu'une discussion sur le secret des
affaires je me bornerai ne me gênait pas
vis-à-vis de ma carrière j'ai regardé
dans le règlement des commission
denquête nous on parle de accepte secret
professionnel et tout ce qui tourne
autour de sécurité et des problèmes de
défense je sais pas si le secret
professionnel s'étend à tout le domaine
du secret des affaires mais c'est votre
travail parce que des fois vous pouvez
communiquer dessus la preuve c'est que
monsieur bernard arnault finalement dans
son correctif à des propos qu'il a tenus
ici nous a dit qu'elle relèverait du
secret des affaires si c'est une
question qui ne transparaît son enquête
pour savoir s'il avait eu des offres et
que vous sont juridiquement nous tenions
à le faire nous le ferons dans les
moyens que vous souhaiter qu'ils soient
discrets nous sommes tes l'elysée
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui ont fait
des heures d'accord nous avons nous
avons signé des engagements de
confidentialité vous nous mettrions en
difficulté que d'aller trahir notre
notre parole vis-à-vis de ces gens là
sont voilà si par contre le président de
la commission voulait savoir si on nous
avons reçu ou non des offres pour enfin
le groupe bertelsmann rtl group a reçu
des offres et que nous avons
l'obligation de les donner bien entendu
nous raisonnons alors je ne vous ai pas
posé la question parce que je jeu de
nous dire qui parce que vous avez raison
et un sujet je vous ai demandé de vous
répondre si vous le souhaitez par souci
de transparence pour savoir quelles sont
les intentions des uns et des autres que
comment se comporte le marché les
acteurs le poser la question est ce que
vous avez eu d'autre offre que celle de
will tf1 je vous ai pas demandé d'aidé
la réponse est oui la réponse est
catégoriquement oui
le groupe m6 je crois que même thomas
sera bien voulu indiquer le groupe m6
est un groupe je vous ai dit bien
portant et c'est la raison pour laquelle
on veut le marié en bonne santé ont pas
le marié un malade
et est ce que monsieur bolloré vous a
proposé une offre
là vont poser des questions directes la
scène on ne voulait pas répondre
d'accord
monsieur de tavernost merci des réponses
que vous nous avez apporté est
évidemment important pour notre
commission les éclairages qu'on nous
avait donné cet après midi